möge die macht mit euch sein leben ganz
ruhig ernst wie so ziemlich jeder mensch
auf diesem planeten und wahrscheinlich
sogar im gesamten sonnensystem habe ich
vor kurzem den neuen star wars film
gesehen
ok zu jener maßen ich hab dir nicht vor
kurzem gesehen sondern bei der ersten
möglichen vorstellung nachts um zwölf
als film rauskam
aber das war es wert keine angst hier
wird nicht gespoilert aber wenn ihr den
jetzt noch nicht gesehen habt dann kann
ich euch irgendwie auch nicht mehr
helfen geht einfach rein guckt euch an
ist ein guter film
wie wahrscheinlich viele von euch bin
ich fasziniert von den lichtschwertern
der yeti ein lichtschwert ist die
wahrscheinlich die komischste waffe
aller science fiction storys die idee
ist eigentlich simpel ein leichter
eleganter griff der eine klinge aus
reinem licht erzeugt und damit beinahe
jedes bekannte material durch schneiden
kann außer einem anderen lichtschwerter
diese waffe ist elegant schnell und in
den richtigen händen mehr als tödlich
und seid mal ganz ehrlich wir hatten
noch nicht den wunsch selber mal ein
lichtschwert in der hand zu halten und
damit alles was einem in den weg kommt
zu zerstückeln
aber wie so ziemlich jeder
kindheitstraum ist das auch nur eine
erfindung von hollywood lichtschwerter
sind physikalischen der echten welt gar
nicht möglich
könnte man meinen kann man in der echten
welt ein echtes lichtschwert bauen
macht euch bereit denn genau das finden
wir jetzt heraus der erste und
offensichtlichste ansatz ein
lichtschwert zu bauen wäre einen laser
zu benutzen
ein laser ist vereinfacht gesagt nur ein
besonders stark gebündelter lichtstrahl
und der lichtenergie trägt anna laser
verheerenden schaden anrichten
wissenschaftler weltweit haben die
laserforschung in den letzten jahren
weit vorangetrieben und viele von ihnen
sind bestimmt auch ziemlich große star
wars fans also wieso haben wir noch kein
echtes laserschwert das größte problem
ist die tatsache dass licht die nervige
eigenschaft besitzt sich gerade aus
weiter zu bewegen solange es auf keinen
widerstand trifft die laser würden nicht
auf magische weise nach einem meter
aufhören sondern geradewegs in den
himmel oder noch schlimmer in die decke
über dir treffen und dort alles
verschmelzen
eine lösung dafür wäre es einen kleinen
spiegel am ende des lichtschwert zu
platzieren
dieser würde dann den leser reflektieren
und die länge des lichtschwert begrenzen
aber dieser spiegel muss auch irgendwie
dort befestigt werden und kleine
halterung stütz streben seiner
natürlichen waffe ziemlich dämlich aus
und wurden ganz nebenbei auch sehr
schnell abbrechen wenn man das schwert
irgendwie gegen schlägt zusätzlich
fressen diese labor laser eine riesige
menge energie
wenn man also kein kleines kraftwerk auf
dem rücken tragen will und einem nicht
mitten im kampf der akten sterben soll
so treffen wir uns endlich bitte laden
mit collagen
bitte laden jetzt hier dann müssen
wissenschaftler einen weg finden
entweder mehr energie in den griff zu
bekommen vielleicht durch einen mini
kernreaktor im griff oder per induktion
aufladen oder sie müssen einen laser
erfinden der weniger energie benötigt
und trotzdem noch alle möglichen
materialien schmelzen könnte aber gut
sagen wir unsere coolen wissenschaftler
kriegen das alles sind dann wäre das
fertige licht stellt immer noch ziemlich
langweilig zum einen weil sich zwei
laserschwerter nicht treffen könnten es
ist licht sie wurden einfach
durcheinander durchfahren
die kämpfe werden damit unmöglich und
zum anderen kann man einen laser bei
normalem tageslicht überhaupt nicht
sehen
das licht ist viel zu stark gebündelt um
in unser auge gestreut zu werden
deswegen brauchen laseranlagen in clubs
auch immer rauch unsichtbar zu sein
die feinen partikel im rauch zerstreuen
das licht in alle richtungen
und erst dann kann man den laser mit dem
auge sehen ok lichtschwerter aus laser
sind eine relativ blöde idee aber wer
sagt denn dass sie aus nicht bestehen
müssen nur weil sie so heißen plasma
könnte die lösung für die waffe unserer
träume sein
plasma ist ein zustand von besonders
heiß im gas und wird auch als vierter
aggregatzustand bezeichnet die teilchen
haben hier so viel energie dass sich
elektronen von ihren atomkernen trennen
und sich frei in einer heißen masse aus
plasma bewegen können
auf natürliche weise entsteht plasma
übrigens für kurze zeit in der nähe von
einschlagenden blitzen ein plasma
lichtschwert oder kurz plasma schwert
vielleicht sollte ich mir dafür die
rechte sichern könnte ungefähr so
funktionieren mit einem dünnen aber
starken höhe fahrten der sowohl gas als
auch elektrische ladung befördern kann
wird gas in langen des schwerts aus
gedampft dann wird spannung auf den
glühfaden gelegt und das gas erhitzt
sich bis zum plasma so was kann ein
bruchteil von einer sekunde passieren
und danach kann man aufgrund der
riesigen hitze alles schmelzen was mit
der klinge in berührung kommt und sehen
können wir das ganze weil das gas
photonen imitiert das besonders geniale
an dieser methode ist dass man nur durch
das austauschen des gas elements die
farbe des lichts schwer zu ändern kann
ein grünes licht erhält man zum beispiel
mit chlorgas und helium wäre das element
der sith denn das führt zu einer rötlich
bis violetten färbung nur nicht einatmen
wie man den glühfaden dann stabil genug
für licht schwertkämpfe bekommt muss die
wissenschaft zwar noch herausfinden
aber ich bin mir auch sicher dass wir
das irgendwann hinkriegen werden es ist
nur eine frage der zeit
das ist nicht die empathie deuce das ist
nicht die mkt ich suche du möchtest
jetzt auf den like -button drücken und
einen kommentar schreiben
ich möchte jetzt auf den like -button
drücken und ein kommentar da lassen
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
und wenn ihr mehr sehen wollt dann
abonniert main kanal und wenn ihre
freunde habt die außen große star wars
fans sind dann zeigt ihnen dieses video
hier bis dahin und möge die macht mit
euch sein